as Sydney braces for its worst heat wave
since 1994 we're here to give you the
hottest gaming news of the week I'm
sorry I promise I'll stop complaining
about the weather oh thank god
[Music]
first up you won't be seeing any more
horror games from Hideo Kojima and
coincidentally it's for the same reason
that I flipped my head at one time I was
on a plane and the person in front of me
was watching paranormal activity on this
screen Kojima told IGN I get scared very
easily actually this is true of Alfred
Hitchcock as well as Steven Spielberg
because they scare easily
because I scare easily it's actually
easy for us to make something that is
scary because we understand what is
scary but while in that process we're
constantly imagining like terrifying
situations so it ends up giving me bad
dreams that's the reason why I don't
want to make a horror game fair enough
Kojima one of the biggest or smallest
stories depending on your personal
preference was gamers perplex bent over
the inclusion of an endowment slider in
Conan exiles fun calm the developer
behind the new open world survival game
weighed in on the customizable wings in
a reddit AMA the dev said they decided
early on that nudity would be a part of
the game as it fits with the Lawrence
setting explaining the slider was a
natural evolution of that especially
seeing we had a similar slider for
breasts equality and all that the in
development version of Conan Exiles is
available right now through Steam early
access and will be coming to Xbox one
sometime this spring a PlayStation 4
version is also in the works though no
release date has been announced fourth
high resolution PC texture pack came out
this week to make your apocalyptic
adventuring even prettier the official
description reads from the blasted
buildings of Lexington to the shores of
Boston Harbor and beyond every location
is enhanced with ultra deluxe details
the same page is currently reporting a
mixed user rating on the pack with many
users saying while there are
improvements they aren't significant
enough to justify the 58 gigabyte file
size in other fallout 4 news Bethesda
planning to release a ps4 patch that
will add support for the ps4 approach
take to talk to Red Dead Redemption 2
this week sort of they were wearing a
talk on behalf of Rockstar but we did
get a few tidbits during an earnings
call CEO Straus Zelnick said obviously
we're incredibly excited about the title
not just Red Dead Redemption - but also
the online offering to come rockstar
will talk more about the title he added
that Red Dead Redemption 2 will have
significant marketing support and
they're not worried about Red Dead
Redemption 2's online mode competing
with Grand Theft Auto online he
explained I think the success of Red
Dead Redemption - which is highly
anticipated will be driven by its
quality and I think that the ongoing
success of Grand Theft Auto online is
driven by its extraordinary quality
finally this week Activision have
updated us as to what they've been up to
in an earnings call a full stick Walter
destiny is still on the docket for
release this year although no date has
been announced as yet Activision has
said the game will broaden the
franchise's global reach and that much
like destiny the first there will be
added on content to come destiny 2 is
rumored to be in development for
consoles as well as PC and Bungie will
be working alongside co-developers high
Moon Studios and Vicarious Visions
Activision also confirmed that a new
Call of Duty game is coming out this
year I know I hope he was sitting down
for that revelation actually said this
year they'll take Call of Duty back to
its roots and traditional combat or once
again takes center stage and that's all
the info we got so make your best
interpretation in that comment box
sledgehammer games are responsible for
development for this year it's week on
site we take a look at some of the best
hacking games you can crack into compare
blood-borne can you come in there and
chat about madhouse difficulty in resi 7
and that's everything we have for you
this week do have an amazing weekend for
more news and more videos please like
and subscribe and we will see you guys
next week
[Music]